Die Flugzeuge und das Radio haben uns näher zusammen gebracht. Die sehr Natur dieser Inventions weint auf den Gutes an Männern, weint auf die universelle Brüderheit, für die Unihilfe uns allen. Millionen von verspärten Männern, Frauen und kleinen Kindern, Schützende eines Systems, das Männern zerstört und die Menschen verletzt. Ich sage zu denen, die mich hören, nicht zu verspärten.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 32, 2 hoch 5. Wir haben wieder mal eine Binärpotenz erreicht und es geht munter weiter mit einem weiteren Gespräch um interessante Technik. Wir haben auch einiges an Feedback bekommen in der letzten Zeit. Ich hab leider jetzt bisher keine Gelegenheit gehabt, das mal aufzuarbeiten, aber das werden wir sicherlich bald mal nachholen. Und das Thema heute dreht sich um die Rettung von Daten, Data Recovery und wir wagen mal einen tiefen Blick auf die Festplatte. Zu Gast ist Vic und der Mikrofon, wie gehabt, Tim Pritlove. Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Und wir steigen auch mal gleich ein ins Thema. Ich sag erstmal Hallo Vic.
Hallo Tim.
Wunderbar. Ja, Datenrettung. Das alte Problem mit den Festplatten. Du hast da ja in den letzten Jahren einige Erfahrungen gesammelt. Kannst vielleicht mal kurz sagen, was so dein Hintergrund ist.
Na ja gut, ich arbeite oder Datenrettung, damit habe ich mich schon sehr lange beschäftigt. Aber seit 1998 arbeite ich, mache ich das auch professionell, sehr professionell, arbeite halt bei einem europäischen Marktführer da und habe eben für Deutschland auch die technische Verantwortung oder habe die bis heute.
Das heißt, du hast schon so einige Festplatten von innen gesehen. Wir haben uns auch schon mal ein paar Bilder angeguckt gestern. Schöner Festplatten-Porn. Ich muss sagen, da war ich ganz schön überrascht bei dem ein oder anderen Bildchen. Mit anderen Worten, bei euch trägt man Festplatten rein, wenn gar nichts mehr geht.
Ja genau, das ist halt, wenn die Festplatten nicht mehr ansprechbar sind oder wenn sie sich eben nicht mehr melden. Normalerweise nimmt man die Festplatte ja im Allgemeinen nicht so wahr. Die ist in den Rechner eingebaut und tut ihren Dienst im Hintergrund. Und die wenigsten Leute haben sie überhaupt je gesehen. Oder es gibt viele Leute, die sich nicht mal darüber bewusst sind, dass in ihrem Rechner ein solches komplexes technisches Teil drinsteckt. Was eben auch mit Mechanik verbunden ist, ist ja eigentlich eins der wenigen Teile, das eine Mechanik hat im Rechner.
Ja, also es geht dabei auch nicht nur um Festplatten dabei bei euch. Also im Prinzip kann man da irgendwie alles vorbei bringen. Also ich schätze mal, es geht auch einiges anderes kaputt. Gibt es noch Bänder?
Ja klar gibt es noch Bänder. Bänder sind irgendwie ein sehr breites Spezialgebiet dieser Dienstleistung oder überhaupt der Datenrettung, weil es so zahllose Formate gibt. Das heißt also man muss im Grunde genommen schon mal einen ganzen Keller voller Laufwerke haben, damit man eben die ganze Vielzahl von Formaten, die historischen und die wenigen aktuellen eben bedienen kann.
Aber da gibt es dann auch wahrscheinlich spezielle Spezialisten, die sich dann auch noch auf diesen gerade auf diesen Vintage-Kram vielleicht spezialisieren oder hat man das dann auch noch irgendwie alles rumliegen?
Das ist die meisten, die sich damit beschäftigen, machen das ja schon ein bisschen länger und haben deswegen eben schon aus Tradition die ganzen älteren Gerätschaften noch herumliegen. Es wird sie sicherlich kaum einer neu anschaffen, zumal das eben auch ein wirklich kleinerer Ausschnitt ist des Geschäfts. Die Hauptdatenrettungsfälle, würde ich mal sagen, über 90 Prozent sind eigentlich Festplatten. Da gibt es dann noch so eine Ecke optische Datenträger, Magneto-optische Datenträger.
Also CDs und DVDs vor allem nehme ich an.
Genau. Oder auch Magneto-optische eben. Das sind diese Mo's, Worms, was auch immer. Das ist ja eigentlich die gleiche Technik, nur mit ein bisschen anderer Firmware.
Ist aber nicht mehr so verbreitet eigentlich. Also Mo's habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Nein, die sind nicht mehr so verbreitet. Und dann gibt es eben jetzt einen Bereich, der, sage ich jetzt mal, neuerdings am wachsen ist. Das sind die Solid-State-Memories. Das heißt also USB-Sticks, Flashkarten und ähnliche Gerätschaften. Was übrigens auch noch ein ganz interessanter neuer Bereich ist, der auch am wachsen ist, also wächst auch wie Teufel, sind Mobiltelefone und PDAs. Also solche, die praktisch die Datenspeicher eingebaut haben und die mit den Datenspeichern untrennbar verbunden sind.
Und die die wichtigen Telefone mal enthalten.
Beispielsweise, oder auch SMS oder manche eben auch Adressdateien. Also das ist eigentlich ein Markt, oder was heißt ein Markt, aber auf jeden Fall ist die Zahl der Fälle da stark steigend.
Ja, das verwundert nichts, zumal wenn jetzt noch die Speicherkapazitäten bei den Geräten noch weiter hochgehen und davon ist ja schwer auszugehen.
Auch beispielsweise Karten von Digitalkameras oder so etwas, wenn jemand eben, sag ich mal, eine sehr lange Reise unternommen hat und hat davon eine Karte voll Fotos mitgebracht, sind die zum Teil eben auch sehr schwer wieder zu beschaffen. In vielen Fällen kann man sie nur wieder beschaffen, indem man die Reise wiederholt und selbst dann ist das nicht sichergestellt.
Und hat schon jemand ein iPod reingetragen?
Da müsste ich jetzt in die Datenbank reingucken, das kann ich so aus dem Kopf nicht sagen, aber ist durchaus denkbar.
Ja, aber ich denke die meisten Leute haben dann doch eh noch irgendwie eine Kopie. Aber wer weiß das schon. In Zweifelsfall sind die Daten ja immer genau da, wo man sie nicht haben will, nämlich auf dem Gerät, was gerade kaputt gegangen ist. Und jeder, der schon mal so einen Headcrash gehabt hat oder einen anderen Defekt bei seiner Platte, der wird diesen Schmerz kennen, das ist dieses unglaubliche Ziehen im Magen, was heißt, oh Gott, ich hätte ja einen Backup machen können. Und in der Regel hat man halt einfach keins gemacht, wobei es natürlich auch den Fall gibt, dass das Backup selber dann nicht funktioniert. Das wird ja sicherlich auch vorkommen. Ich würde mal ganz gerne einschwenken und mal so ein bisschen gucken, was sind eigentlich die konkreten Probleme sind. Also angenommen, ich habe jetzt eine Festplatte und auf einmal geht irgendwie gar nichts mehr. Das Betriebssystem sagt irgendwie nur irks und meint so, ja, da geht nichts.
Na gut, das Betriebssystem, im allgemeinen startet das Betriebssystem ja gar nicht, weil das ja von der Platte geladen wird. Also insofern wird schon eine Instanz vor dem Betriebssystem sagen, du, deine Platte ist leider kaputt. Platten sind halt normale, sage ich jetzt mal, normale technische Geräte, die halt einfach auch kaputt gehen. Das heißt also, wie jedes andere technische Gerät hat so eine Festplatte eine Lebensdauer, die man nicht so genau vorhersagen kann. Es gibt also welche, die Jahrzehnte halten, und es gibt auch welche, die relativ schnell kaputt gehen. Und irgendwo zwischen einem Monat und drei Jahrzehnten wird auch deine Festplatte sterben.
Aber gibt es da irgendwie einen Trend? Wird das irgendwie besser oder schlechter, oder war das schon immer mal so und mal so?
Ja, da gibt es eben, da gibt es, das ist eigentlich mehr so ein bisschen ein Glücksspiel. Da gibt es also Serien, die anfälliger sind, oder die ein spezielles Problem haben, und andere Serien wiederum die andere Probleme haben. Also man kann das nicht speziell auf Hersteller oder ähnliches zuordnen. Aber es gibt halt schon bestimmte Modelle, die für bestimmte Probleme anfälliger sind. Das sind halt, die sind ja in der Konstruktion sehr unterschiedlich. Da gibt es eine Mechanik drin. Da ist ja beispielsweise der Plattenstapel, der sich dreht, da sind Lager drin. Nun, ich meine jetzt, jedem wird klar sein, dass auch ein Lager nicht ewig hält. Und es sind ja eben nicht nur in dem Plattenstapel Lager drin, sondern auch die Lagerung der Kopfträger. Das muss ja auch relativ präzise vonstatten gehen und da ist auch immer sehr viel Bewegung drin.
Da kommen wir ja schon zum interessanten Punkt, nämlich wie so eine Platte aufgestellt ist. Also ich meine, wenn so Leute, die jetzt nicht so mit Computertechnik vertraut sind, mich mit großen Augen anschauen und fragen, warum ich, warum meine Daten, wie kann das überhaupt passieren? Und ich dann erstmal klar machen muss, dass es sich bei einer Festplatte um ein lautes, sich viel bewegendes, hoch filigranes Gerät handelt, was sich mit Abertausenden von Umdrehungen pro Minute durch die Gegend bewegt. Dann schauen sie mich halt immer erst groß an und erst in dem Moment wird ihnen bewusst, dass das, was da halt die ganze Zeit vor sich hinsirrt, so eine filigrane Feinmechanik ist, mit so wenig Toleranzen, dass man sich ja eigentlich das auch selber ausrechnen kann, dass es eine große Federanfälligkeit gibt.
Nein, man kann nicht sagen, dass sie anfällig sind, aber jeder, der eine Festplatte mal angefasst hat, die nicht gekühlt wird, der wird schon feststellen, dass sie einen gewissen Energieumsatz hat. Jetzt alleine der Energieumsatz und die Wärme und die Ausdehnung und das Gegenteil davon übt natürlich auf die Mechanik eine gewisse Belastung aus. Und nicht nur auf die Mechanik, auch Elektronik, beispielsweise Halbleiter, neigen dazu, dass die Dotierungen beginnen zu diffundieren, je wärmer man sie betreibt. Und so hat eben eine Platte, jede Platte hat eine Lebensdauer und jedem, dem man oder jeder, der da Zweifel hat, dem kann man sagen, auch deine Festplatte wird sterben. Es ist nur eine Frage des Zeitpunktes.
Wenn man, ja, vielleicht mal kurz ein bisschen in die Festplatte reinkriechen, meine, einige werden sicherlich im Prinzip wissen, wie die aufgebaut ist, aber ich würde das ganz gerne mal auch unter dem Gesichtspunkt der Brennpunkte betrachten, wo sozusagen am meisten kaputt geht. Also zunächst einmal hat man dort die rotierenden Scheiben mit der Magnetbeschichtung, wo die eigentlichen Daten gespeichert werden und dazwischen ist halt dieser mehrfingrige Arm, je nach Modell, je nachdem wie viele Scheiben man hat, der eben, je nachdem wo er eben gerade lesen muss, da in unglaublicher Geschwindigkeit hin und her brutzelt. Und dann natürlich noch die Elektronik, die in der Platte mit eingebaut ist, die das Ganze steuert.
Na gut, so eine Platte natürlich hat ein paar mehr Komponenten. Ich hätte jetzt von der Elektronik angefangen, weil das sozusagen die Seite ist, die zum Computer zeigt. Diese Elektronik ist im Prinzip wieder ein kompletter Computer, der eigenen lokalen Speicher hat, also sowohl beschreibbaren als auch nur lesbaren Speicher. Der hat eine Schnittstelle zur Computerseite hin, die eben von diesem Computer auch bedient wird. Das heißt also, diese Schnittstelle sind heutzutage eigentlich unterhalten sich da zwei Computer über diese Schnittstelle. In der Anfangszeit der Festplatten war das so, dass der Teil, der sich mit der Festplatte, mit den Signalen beschäftigt hat, noch im Computer war. Das heißt also, der eigentliche Controller, so hat man das früher genannt, der war im Computer drin und hat sich dann mit den, sag ich mal, nur unwesentlich aufbereiteten Analogsignalen von der Festplatte beschäftigt.
Reden wir da von diesen MFM-Controllern, die so frühen PCs drin waren?
Ja genau, beispielsweise MFM-Controller, das waren definitiv welche, wo der Hauptteil der Dekodierungslogik eben im Computer gewesen ist.
Wofür steht das MFM?
Das steht für Modified Frequency Modulation. Das ist halt ein Aufzeichnungsverfahren. Also da würde ich jetzt nicht zu tief einsteigen. Das heute gängige Aufzeichnungsverfahren ist, also jetzt mal von den Symbolen her RLL. Das ist die Abkürzung for Run Lengths Limited. Das war eigentlich schon gleich das Aufzeichnungsverfahren, was nach MFM kam. Und das ist eigentlich eine Kategorie Bezeichnung für einen ganzen Strauß von Aufzeichnungsverfahren, weil es eben verschiedene RLL-Quotes gibt.
Das sagt halt aus, dass im Prinzip die allerersten Platten keine eigene wirkliche Intelligenz besaßen, sondern im Wesentlichen ein Stecker, um von außen angesteuert zu werden.
Das ist korrekt. Die Schnittstelle, die erste, die man in PC-Festplatten gesehen hat, die ST-506-Schnittstelle, ist eigentlich, das hat man auch an den Steckern schon gesehen, sehr ähnlich der Floppy-Schnittstelle der früheren für Floppy-Discs. Da ist dann halt, das ist im Prinzip eine Floppy-ähnliche Schnittstelle, wo dann halt noch ein Hochgeschwindigkeitsübertragungskabel hinzugekommen ist. Das ist halt eine evolutionäre Entwicklung, würde ich mal sagen, gewesen und die nächste evolutionäre Entwicklung war dann, dass dieser Controller mitsamt seinen Kabeln auf die Festplatten-Elektronik gewandert ist. Das nannte man dann damals IDE, Integrated Device Electronics. Das heißt eigentlich nichts weiter als, dass der Controller auf die Festplattenplatine gewandert ist. Naja und der hatte dann, damit war dann der damals übliche PC-Bus, der AT-Bus, wanderte dann eben zur Festplattenschnittstelle. Das heißt also, man hatte eine vereinfachte Variante dieser IBM PC AT-Slots dann sozusagen über ein Kabel verlängert bis zur Festplatte, damit man dort den Controller versorgen konnte. Naja und der nächste Schritt war dann halt, dass man diese Schnittstelle, sag ich jetzt mal, im Prinzip beibehalten hat, aber die Platten dann noch intelligenter gemacht hat.
Ja, heute kennt man ja eigentlich nur noch IDE oder ATA und die SCSI-Festplatten. Das sind ja so die...
Nö, eigentlich nicht, sondern das sind jetzt auch noch Evolutionsschritte, die zwischen dem von damals und dem von heute sind. Also man hat dann eben diese ATA-Schnittstelle, die ja eigentlich nach wie vor immer noch so ähnlich wie ein ATA, wo es funktioniert, da gibt es immer noch IO-Ports und Register und ähnliches, die man halt ein bisschen mehr abstrahiert und hat dann da...
Die Abkürzung auch anders umbenannt, damit es cooler klingt.
Genau, genau. Und die hat man dann im Prinzip dieselbe Protokoll dann auf eine serielle Schnittstelle gehoben, weil die eben von den Kabeln her einfach zu händeln sind. Da sind halt weniger Strippen drin und mittlerweile hat man das eben ganz gut im Griff auch serielle Schnittstellen relativ schnell zu betreiben. Und da ist dann eben die S-ATA-Schnittstelle draus geworden. SCSI, also SCSI ist eigentlich einen ganz anderen Weg gegangen. Da gab es schon von vornherein ein Protokoll, was auf CDBs basierte, also Command Distributor Blocks oder so ähnlich heißen die, meine ich. Und wo man also schon einen sehr viel, einen sehr viel höheren Level an Abstraktion auf dem Bus gefahren hat, wo also von vornherein klar war, dass die jeweiligen Teilnehmer an diesem Bus intelligent sein mussten. Das war bei den AT-Platten nicht von vornherein klar. Und mittlerweile gibt es eben jetzt die Konvergenzbestrebung, dass es eben SCSI jetzt auch in Serial gibt. Das heißt also, dass man auch diese breiten Kabel, diese breiten kurzen Kabel durch lange dünne ersetzt. Und die Konvergenz liegt einfach daran, dass jetzt, also SAS heißt das, Serial Attached Scasi, dass das also bis hin zu den Steckverbindern wiederum kompatibel mit Serial ATA ist. Das heißt also, dass diese beiden Techniken, die eigentlich immer irgendwo im Wettbewerb standen, jetzt wieder konvergieren, so dass man also beispielsweise SATA-Platten in SAS-RAS reinstecken kann und die funktionieren.
Okay, dann schreiten wir aber dann trotzdem mal durchs Kabel in die Festplatte rein. Weil da wird es ja dann eigentlich erst richtig interessant. Jetzt habe ich hier meine kaputte Festplatte und nichts geht mehr. Wie geht man da jetzt ran? Also was kann man da jetzt herausfinden?
Na gut, jetzt muss man ja mal sehen, wo denn das Problem ist. Ich meine, wenn sie sich noch, also wenn sie noch beginnt, sich zu drehen, dann ist ja schon mal relativ wahrscheinlich, dass die Elektronik in irgendeiner Form funktioniert, weil die auch den Motor steuert.
Das heißt, wenn sie gar nicht erst anläuft, ist das schon mal so ein Hinweis, das könnte bedeuten, dass...
Dann würde ich als erstes mal die Elektronik testen, ob die richtig funktioniert. Und die Elektronik ist eben nicht nur reine Hardware, sondern da steckt eben auch eine Firmware drin. Und die Firmware von Festplatten ist mittlerweile ziemlich fett geworden. Das heißt also, da ist ein Haufen Software drin, in diesem Controller-Platin. Na ja, und dann kann man ja versuchen, mal mit dieser Platine einmal von der Rechnerschnittstelle herzusprechen oder eben auch andere Tests unternehmen, ob die eben einmal frei funktioniert. Und wenn sie das nicht tut, dann müsste man sie eben reparieren oder austauschen.
Das heißt, Platinwechsel kann häufiger schon mal gleich zum Erfolg führen, weil einfach nur ein Chip verreckt ist.
Platinwechsel ist sehr problematisch, würde ich heute auch nicht mehr dem geneigten Anwender oder Service-Menschen empfehlen, weil diese Platinen zum Teil eben auch Informationen enthalten, die nur speziell zu dieser einen Festplatte oder nur speziell zu dieser Revision passen. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt also die Platine tausche, kann es passieren, dass ich damit verhindere, dass ich die Daten noch retten kann. Denn wenn ich die praktisch mal mit einer falschen Platinen-Software in Betrieb genommen habe, kann das auch dazu führen, dass der Teil, der eigentlich auf dem Medium gespeichert ist, in Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird und dann sozusagen den Weg versperrt zu einer erfolgreichen Datenrettung.
Das heißt, da sind so auch Kalibrationsinformationen drin, die dann vielleicht nur auf diese eine spezielle Platte?
Ja, so etwas. Entweder auf die eine spezielle oder eben auf genau exakt diese Controller-Version. Und ein Teil der Firmware wird eben von Medium geladen. Das ist also auch so, dass jetzt nicht mehr nur noch die PCs von der Platte booten, sondern auch...
Die Platten booten von der Platte?
Die Platten-Elektronik bootet zum Teil von der Platte. Ja, das ist heute absolut üblich. Das heißt also, dass eben ein großer Teil der Firmware auf dem Medium gespeichert ist an einem Bereich, die sozusagen dem Betriebssystem nicht zugänglich ist. Diesen Bereich kriegt man normalerweise nie zu sehen, es sei denn man verfügt eben über die Informationen mit Hilfe von Wendekommandos, also speziellen Techniken darauf zuzugreifen. Wenn man die über die verfügt, dann kann man sie auch lesen und zum Teil auch schreiben. Ansonsten kriegt man die nie zu sehen. Aber eben der Controller bootet zum Teil von der Platte. Das ist heute absolut üblich.
Und was mache ich damit da, wenn man jetzt die Platine nicht so ohne weiteres aussaustauschen kann, aber man weiß, es liegt daran?
Ja, dann muss man eben weiter suchen gehen. Dann muss man halt schauen, ob die Firmware noch gesund ist auf der Platine und ob man die eben beispielsweise auf eine andere Platine übertragen kann und damit dann quasi den Zustand vor dem Defekt der Platine wieder herstellen kann.
Okay, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass meine Platte jetzt ordentlich funkt und sich durchaus die Software bemüht, da was zu machen, aber es gibt halt komische Geräusche.
Komische Geräusche sind eigentlich typischerweise ein Zeichen dafür, dass was mit dem Medium nicht stimmt, denn die entstehen dadurch im Allgemeinen, also diese Klötergeräusche, die sicherlich oder die einige sicherlich schon mal gehört haben, die entstehen eigentlich dadurch, dass die Positionierung nicht möglich ist. Das heißt, dazu muss man erklären, wie die Positionierung funktioniert. Das ist bei den modernen Platten eigentlich immer ein Voice-Coil-Antrieb, also praktisch eine Spule, die sich in einem Magnetfeld frei bewegen kann und dort eben nur durch einen Regelkreis an eine bestimmte Stelle befördert wird. Es gibt also nicht wie früher diese Stepper-Motoren, die auf einer bestimmten Position einrasten, sondern das Einrasten dieser Köpfe auf bestimmte Positionen geschieht also rein durch eine sogenannte Servo-Elektronik, die tatsächlich magnetisch auf der Platte aufgezeichnete Informationen auswertet, um dort die Position, die Ist-Position des Kopfträgers festzustellen und vergleicht das mit der Soll-Position und gibt eben mit einem gewissen Regel-Algorithmus dazwischen eben die Differenz dann auf diese Magnetspule, die dazu führt oder was dann dazu führt, dass diese Position angefahren wird. Wenn nun aber erstmal muss ja, müssen ja die Köpfe erstmal irgendeine Servoinformation finden, um eben festzustellen, wo bin ich denn eigentlich. Und wenn das misslingt, also der Algorithmus funktioniert halt einfach so, geben wir doch einfach mal ein bisschen Feld auf unsere Spule und warten mal eine gewisse Zeit, bis wir Servoinformation sehen. Und wenn diese Zeit abgelaufen ist, dann versuchen wir es mal mit dem umgekehrten Polarität und fahren mal in eine andere Richtung und gucken mal, ob wir eine Servoinformation sehen. Und das passiert halt auch periodisch, was dann dazu führt, wenn keine Servoinformation unterm Kopf vorbei kommt, dass es dann eben einmal am einen mechanischen Anschlag klang sagt und dann eben wieder zurück fährt und am anderen mechanischen Anschlag wieder Klang macht. Das heißt also, das ist eigentlich ein relativ deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass eben keine Servoinformation gefunden wurde. Dafür kann es mehrere Ursachen geben. Es kann beispielsweise sein, dass die Platte magnetisch gelöscht wurde mit einem Endmaktisierungsgerät oder so etwas. Es kann sein, dass die Köpfe kaputt sind und deswegen keine Servoinformation lesen können. Es kann eben im gesamten Signalverarbeitungsweg der sogenannten Servo-Loop liegen. Das heißt, es kann bis hin zu Elektronikfehlern sein, Anschlussfehlern zwischen den Köpfen, Vorverstärker, was weiß ich. Da muss man eben den gesamten Servo-Schaltkreis einmal in Augenschein nehmen und eben auch sehen. Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass eben schon die gesamte magnetische Oberfläche der Platte abgehobelt ist. Dann ist natürlich auch die Servoinformation mit weg. Dann kann man im Falle von Glasplatten manchmal durchgucken bis zum Gehäuseboden und da gibt es dann sicher auch keine Servoinformation mehr.
Im Falle von Glasplatten heißt das, dass manche Scheiben in Festplatten tatsächlich aus Glas bestehen?
Das stimmt. Also manche bestehen aus Glas und manche bestehen halt aus Aluminium oder irgendwelchen Legierungen. Die eigentliche Datenaufzeichnungsschicht ist nur eine sehr, sehr dünne, also im Mikrometerbereich dünne Oberfläche auf diesen Medien.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das abgehobelt ist, das ist das, was man quasi als Headcrash bezeichnet? Also wenn der Lesekopf mit der Platte selber in Berührung kommt?
Ja, wobei eben alleine das in Berührung kommen muss noch nicht unbedingt zu einem Schaden führen, denn es gibt auch durchaus noch einige Platten, wo die Köpfe außer Betrieb eben auf dem Medium landen. Das ist dort an der Stelle ein bisschen aufgeraut, sogar damit die Medien eben nicht diese durch die Adhersionskraft auf den Oberflächen kleben bleiben. Das könnte unter Umständen eben dazu führen, dass die Platte nicht mehr dreht oder die Köpfe abreißt beim bei der ersten Umdrehung. Deswegen werden eben die Landezonen mit Hilfe von kleinen Laser-Pünktchen aufgeräumt. Damit die halt ein bisschen rau sind, damit die Köpfe darauf nicht kleben. Normalerweise ist ein Headcrash eben, wenn etwas unsanft oder wenn irgendein Fremdkörper beispielsweise zwischen Oberfläche und Kopf gerät und dadurch quasi ein Kratzer in die Platte gemacht wird. Das heißt also, da entsteht halt eben normalerweise typischerweise konzentrische Kratzer in der Platte.
Das sind diese Saturn-Ringe, das hat man ja auch auf den Fotos gesehen, also entweder einer oder mehrere. Häufig war der Ring dann immer in der Mitte?
Ja, es gibt irgendwie bei den meisten Platten halt so eine Position, wo der Kopf hinfährt, wenn er überhaupt nicht angesteuert wird, also wenn er in Ruhe, in Ruhelage.
Die Parkzone heißt das, oder?
Nein, das ist sie nicht. Sondern das ist halt die, wo der Kopf von sich aus mechanisch hin will, wenn er keine magnetische Ansteuerung bekommt. Das ist nicht die Parkzone. Die Parkzone ist normalerweise der innerste Teil des verfügbaren Mediums, weil dort eben auch die Oberfläche, also das ist der, den man am leichtesten verschmerzen kann, weil der eben am wenigsten Oberfläche hat und man dadurch eben wenig Datenaufzeichnungskapazität durch die Parkzone verliert. Deswegen ist die eben traditionell innen.
Und aber in der Mitte ist dieser Ruhebereich, wo...
Ja, wo eben der Kopf zum Liegen kommen würde, wenn man ihm keine Ansteuerung zuteilwerden lässt, nicht? Und an der Stelle ist natürlich im Fall, wenn jetzt eben so ein Headcrash entsteht, wird ja auch meistens durch diesen Kratzer werden weitere Partikel aus der Oberfläche rausgelöst, die dann wiederum sozusagen zu so einer Art Lawineffekt führen und dann ebenzu wieder noch mehr Fremdkörper zwischen Kopf und Oberfläche bringen. Und dann eben wird die Schramme immer tiefer und immer breiter. Und ja, der Klassische. Und dann entstehen eben die Klasse der ersten Satorenringen. Und wenn die Köpfe noch ein bisschen bewegt werden, entstehen eben auch mal mehr.
So eine Festplatte ist ja quasi so ein Rheinstraum, oder? Ist da eigentlich ein Vakuum drin? Also wird da komplett alle Luft rausgenommen, oder ist das nur sauber?
Nein, da ist kein Vakuum drin, sondern ganz im Gegenteil. Die haben sogar Luftlöcher drin, die allerdings mit Filtern verdeckt sind. Das heißt also, dass die Luft da drin schon sehr sauber ist, aber es entspricht dem Umgebungsdruck. Das heißt also, es ist kein Unter- oder Überdruck innerhalb des Gehäuses. Das würde zu verschiedenen Problemen führen, aber das würde jetzt zu weit gehen, wenn wir darauf eingehen. Ich kann auf jeden Fall sagen, Fakt ist, es ist dort kein Vakuum, aber es ist sauber. Im Normalfall werden die eben im Rheinraum zusammengebaut. Dadurch sollen da eben keine Partikel drin sein, eben wegen dieser Gefahr, dass die halt einfach mal in einen ungünstigen Moment zwischen Kopf und Oberfläche geraten könnten und dann eben so einen Crash verursachen.
Und im Rheinstraum nimmt er sie wahrscheinlich auch auseinander. Also wenn jetzt so die Partikel abgescheuert sind, du meintest irgendwie bei der einen Festplatte, die wir uns angeschaut haben, da ist da schon richtig so ein kleines Staubsäckchen da in der Staubeckchen entstanden.
Ja gut, wenn die eben sehr lange laufen, wenn die sehr lange laufen, noch nach dem eigentlichen technischen Ausfall, was auf Disk-Error passieren kann zum Beispiel, wenn beim RAID 5 die erste Platte ausfällt, dann merkt das ja oft lange Zeit keiner. Und wenn die sehr lange gelaufen sind, dann ist halt so ein typisches Erscheinungsbild, dass die gesamte magnetische Oberflächenbeschichtung eben in Form eines kleinen Häufchens in der Ecke liegt, wenn man die aufmacht.
Die ganzen Nullen und Einsen zusammengefegt in der Ecke.
Genau, also die sammeln sich dann eben auch immer in bestimmten Stellen und dann kann man so richtig sehen, wie da so ein kleines, kleines Staubhäufchen in der Ecke ist. Sondern das sind dann sozusagen die Daten. Und man kann dann eben auch sehr deutlich, man kann eben durch die Glasplatten so schön durchgucken bis zum Grund, dass man also dann...
Das heißt, da kann man den Kunden anrufen und sagen, wir haben ihre Daten gefunden, sie befinden sich in dieser kleinen Plastiktüte. Ja, und das ist also jetzt quasi der physikalische Bereich. Gibt es da noch weitere Vorfälle oder Analysen, die wir jetzt noch nicht so beleuchtet haben, die da noch auftreten können?
Naja, es gibt alles mögliche. Das ist halt ein sehr breites und auch recht interessantes Feld. Es gibt eben da die verschiedenen Lagerschäden und elektronische und sonstige Phänomene, was da alles passieren kann. Also die Liste ist endlos lang, was so einer Platte alles passieren kann, bis hin zum runterfallen. Dann können sich sogar die Platten, sage ich jetzt mal, auf den Plattenstapel verschieben, wenn sie beispielsweise jetzt längs der Plattenoberfläche einen starken Stoß erlebt. Wenn sie quer der Plattenoberfläche einen starken Stoß erlebt, dann führt das meistens zu kleinen Einschlägen des Kopfes an verschiedenen Stellen auf den Oberflächen.
Das sind diese Spots, diese einzelnen kleinen...
Ja, wir nennen das halt Spots. Man sieht dann eben einzelne kleine Einschläge auf den Medienoberflächen. Da weiß man dann eben immer sozusagen, dass eine Kraft eben 90 Grad auf das Medium, oder ich sage jetzt mal, nicht zwangsweise 90 Grad, aber eben nicht entlang des Mediums auf das Medium gewirkt hat. Bei Kräften entlang des Mediums verschieben sich meistens die Platten. Das führt dann dazu, oder das kann man sehr leicht erkennen, dass wenn man so eine Platte in Betrieb nimmt, dass die eine unheimliche Vibration von sich gibt, weil eben dadurch auch eine Unwucht im Plattenstapel entstehen kann.
Wenn man sich jetzt also angenommen, wir haben jetzt die Platte zumindest mal wieder zum Laufen bekommen, und es ist jetzt irgendwie möglich, Daten davon zu lesen. Das ist ja die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man nicht alle Daten lesen kann, relativ hoch. Letztlich geht es ja nicht nur darum, dass das Ding wieder dreht, sondern im Surface-Fall möchte man ja die Daten auch wieder haben. Das heißt, danach, nach dieser physikalischen Analyse, beginnt im Prinzip die logische Analyse?
Ja, es haben ja nicht alle Platten einen physikalischen Fehler. Es kann eben auch aus anderen Gründen Datenverlust eintreten, wie beispielsweise jetzt nur mal, dass jemand die Daten über eine Platte formatiert hat, versehentlich, oder auf der falschen Platte eben etwas überschrieben hat.
Oder das Betriebssystem absturzt und das Datalsystem ist nicht mehr konsistent?
Genau, und die Betriebssystemeigenen Tools können das eben nicht mehr herstellen oder reparieren. Das sind auch solche Fälle, da trennen wir halt in physikalische und logische Datenrettung. Logische Datenrettung muss eigentlich immer gemacht werden. Also die physikalische eben nicht immer, sondern nur, wenn die Platte kaputt ist. Die logische Analyse ist eben, die umfasst so Dinge wie Partitionen und Dateisysteme und so etwas. Das heißt also die Organisationsstruktur eigentlich der Daten. Das heißt eigentlich im Prinzip eine strukturelle Analyse.
Das heißt, da muss man jetzt erstmal gucken, was ist da für ein Dateisystem drauf?
Genau, es können ja auch mehrere drauf sein. Ich meine, man könnte so eine Festplatte ja auch mit verschiedenen Partitionen haben, die wiederum verschiedene Dateisysteme enthalten. Das ist durchaus möglich. Es gibt auch die Fälle, wo eben ein Dateisystem über mehrere Platten verteilt ist. Aus verschiedenen Gründen, sei es also ein Disk Array, ein RAID oder sei es Logical Volume Manager, sei es ein Dateisystem, was generell von der Konstruktion aus hier verteilt ist. Es gibt ja sogar Dateisysteme, die über mehrere Rechner verteilt sind. Und insofern ist eben diese logische Struktur der Daten eben sehr vielfältig. Und da gibt es auch ein sehr breitbandiges Feld, einen Ansatz zu finden, um sozusagen diese Daten wieder herauszuziehen, aus dem Teich von BITS.
Das heißt, ihr geht dann mit Tools ran, die erstmal, es kann ja auch sein, dass überhaupt kein Vorwissen darüber besteht, was da sich eigentlich mal drauf befunden haben soll. Ich weiß nicht, wie häufig das ist, aber es ist ja denkbar. Also wahrscheinlich geht man mit allen möglichen Analyse-Tools ran und schaut erstmal, was da der Ist-Zustand ist.
Na ja, gut, die Kunden geben darauf eigentlich immer mehr oder weniger verwertbare Hinweise. Das hängt eben auch davon ab, wie weit oder wie viel der Kunde über Rechner weiß. Also ich sehe hier gerade einen Mac auf dem Tisch. Mac-User sind typischerweise die, solange die Platte noch irgendeinen Piep sagt, dann lassen sie erstmal alle Utilities, die sie irgendwo finden konnten, darauf los. Und das erschwert eben die logische Arbeit sehr erheblich, sodass wir eigentlich immer glücklich sind, dass wenn bei Mac-User die Platte so kaputt ist, dass sie da eben nichts mehr verschlimmbessern können.
Ist das dann bei Windows so sehr viel besser?
Die Windows-User sind nicht so verspielt. Wenn der Rechner ihnen sagt, die Platte ist im Eimer, dann glauben sie das im Allgemeinen auch.
Ich meine, natürlich auch nachvollziehbar, dass man es erstmal mit verfügbaren Tools probiert, bevor man relativ kostspielige Analyse da ansetzen soll. Weil Daten sind einem zwar immer was wert, aber ob sie einem dann auch unbedingt die Kosten einer professionellen Datenrettung wert sind, das steht ja nochmal auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Ich wollte nochmal kurz nachfragen, bei CD-ROMs und DVDs kann man da eigentlich noch irgendwas tun, wenn da jetzt Fehler sind? Also ich meine, das ist wahrscheinlich vergebene Liebesmüh. Die Dinger sind dann irgendwie zerkratzt oder haben sonst irgendwelche Schichtfehler? Oder gibt es da noch Möglichkeiten, die Dinger nochmal anzuschleifen oder sowas?
Ja, da gab es ja mal, da gibt es ja einige Beiträge, oder ne, besonders einen Beitrag in der CT, wo die sich mal mit diesen, gerade mal mit CD-ROMs und so etwas beschäftigt haben und haben da eben auch diese verschiedenen, lustigen, chinesischen Poliertools ausprobiert, die man da kaufen kann. Und ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht mehr so genau an den Tenor, aber man kann natürlich einiges versuchen da auf dem Gebiet.
Aber du bist da skeptisch.
Na ja, wir haben natürlich da auch so unsere Techniken, was wir damit treiben und was auf jeden Fall immer ein ziemlicher Gau ist, ist, wenn die Aufzeichnungsschicht sich von dem Polycarbonat-Träger gelöst hat. Das ist eigentlich immer ein ziemlicher Gau. Das passiert besonders gerne, wenn man eben auf der Oberseite da Aufkleber anbringt oder so etwas. Das würde ich also nicht empfehlen aus meiner Praxis.
Ah, okay, verstehe, weil das dann durchfrisst.
Ja, und das kann eben auch dazu führen, dass sich eben die Aufzeichnungsschicht vom Polycarbonat...
Das ist ja sehr populär, so diese kleinen Tin-Strahldrucker-Etiketten und so.
Ja, genau, und das würde ich lieber nicht machen.
Okay, ja, dann vielleicht nochmal so zurück zu den Datalsystemen. Also, Datalsysteme gibt es ja viele. Meistens Betriebssysteme implizieren auch immer irgendeinen bestimmten Typ von Datalsystemen. Und da Windows wird sich, denke ich, heutzutage häufig NTFS vorfinden, bisweilen dann wohl auch noch das FAT-Filesystem, auf Mac ist es fast durchgehend HFS+. Und unter Linux hat man es halt mit diesen Unix-Filesystemen zu tun, UFS, X2, X3, wie sie alle heißen. Filesysteme gibt es ja wirklich eine ganze Batterie. Inwieweit sind denn jetzt diese Datalsysteme dafür vorbereitet, einen potenziellen Datenverlust vorzubeugen?
Also im Allgemeinen hat man den Eindruck, die Konstrukteure der Datalsysteme relativ wenig sorgen. Die betrachten es meistens einfach nicht als ihr Problem. Also ich sag mal, Datalsysteme werden eigentlich konstruiert, um möglichst schnell die Dateien wiederzufinden oder eben ein bestimmtes vorhersehbares Zeitverhalten eines Betriebssystems hervorzubringen, sodass bei der Konstruktion, glaube ich, da nicht so viel getan wird, die Rettungsmöglichkeiten zu berücksichtigen. Das kann man ja letztlich nur durch Redundanz erreichen. Und die Redundanz ist eigentlich in den Datalsystemen relativ gering normalerweise, weil die halt auch Platz kostet.
Ja, und auch Zeit im Zweifelsfall, wenn man Dinge zwei-, dreimal schreiben muss.
Ganz genau, ganz genau. Und die Datalsystem-Schreiberlinge betrachten halt die Redundanz eher als das Problem der darunter liegenden Hardware. Also sagen dann ja, wenn du Redundanz willst, dann kauft ihr halt ein Rät, nicht?
Aber auch wenn die Fallsysteme nicht unbedingt auf Datensicherheit hin optimiert wurden, werden sie ja sicherlich bestimmte Eigenschaften haben, die das eine Fallsystem mehr oder weniger angreifbar machen.
Ja, das stimmt. Jedes hat so seine Vor- und Nachteile. Da gibt es ein paar Klassen, da gibt es halt die Dateisysteme, die mit File-Tables arbeiten, also beispielsweise NTFS und das gute alte Files 11 von DEC, worauf das NTFS ja letztlich aufbaut.
Vom VMS-Betriebssystem.
Richtig, richtig. Das ist ja noch da aus den 70er Jahren.
Ist der gleiche Entwickler gewesen, der dahinter steckt hat?
Ja, soweit ich weiß, war das der gleiche Entwickler. Was mir allerdings vollkommen schleierhaft ist, warum sie Errungenschaften, die es damals schon gab, für die erste Version von NTFS wieder weggelassen haben. Um sie dann gerade kürzlich bei Windows XP wieder einzuführen, es war wahrscheinlich Firmenpolitik oder so etwas.
Was war das, so ein kleines Feature, was die Datenrettung vereinfacht hat?
Ja, das war, also das File 11b war schon relativ robust, weil eben die MFT-Records ihre eigene Nummer wussten.
MFT ist Master File Table?
Table, richtig, richtig. Das ist eben die Liste aller Dateien sozusagen. Die hieß bei dem VMS-Betriebssystem noch ein bisschen anders. Da hieß sie Index.f.sys. Aber gut, das ist technisch dasselbe. Und da hatte eben jeder Eintrag in dieser Liste einfach eine laufende Nummer. Und bei der ersten NTFS-Version haben sie einfach gesagt, na gut, diese laufende Nummer können wir einsparen, weil wir wissen ja, wir brauchen die Liste ja nur von oben bis unten durchzählen, dann wissen wir ja, welche Nummer er hat. Was allerdings eben im Falle eines Datenverlustes, wenn da eben Listeneinträge fehlen, durchaus zu Schwierigkeiten führen kann, besonders wenn es eben Referenzen auf diese Listennummern gibt, obwohl sie nicht davor stehen.
Programmierer gehen immer so ein bisschen von einer idealen Welt aus.
Genau, obwohl eben das kann man ja nun dem Entwickler nicht nachsagen, denn bei Files 11 hat er das ja durchaus schon berücksichtigt, dieses Problem. Und warum sie es nun?
Das ist ja die Frage, aus welcher Motivation heraus er das da eingebaut hat. Vielleicht hat er sich einfach nur gedacht, ich zähl mal, schreib's einfach mal rein und mach mir keine weiteren Gedanken dazu. Das ist alles Mutmaßung.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Bei jemandem, der sozusagen ein Datalsystem am grünen Tisch entwickelt, dass der da ein Feld einbaut, besonders eben in einer Zeit, wo Plattenplatz noch recht teuer ist, ein Feld einführt, was keinen Sinn hat. Das war damals ein absoluter Frevel, wäre das gewesen, weil eben Plattenkapazität damals noch echt teuer war.
Und heißt das, dass jetzt mit dieser Wiedereinführung dieser fortlaufenden Nummer die Robustheit von NTFS gut ist?
Das heißt auf jeden Fall, dass sie gestiegen ist. Die anderen Klassen von Datalsystemen, wenn wir jetzt zur Robustheit übergehen, kann man auch sagen, dass eine gewisse Robustheit auch die B-Tree-Datalsysteme haben, zu denen HFS Plus und beispielsweise Reiser FS, XFS ähnliche gehören, weil die eben die Datalsystemstrukturen relativ, sag ich jetzt mal, schön über die Platte verstreuen. Eine andere Art von Robustheit...
Also B-Tree ist so ein Balanced Tree?
Genau.
Also so eine hierarchische Struktur, wo die dann die Blöcke einfach gleichmäßig verteilt werden. Und das hat welchen Vorteil?
Naja, dass wenn man eben eine lokale Beschädigung hat, dass dann eben nur ein Teil dieser Information fehlt. Wenn man jetzt beispielsweise bei einem FAD-Datalsystem eine lokale Beschädigung im äußeren Bereich hat, dann sind einfach, also beim FAD-Datalsystem liegen eben beide File Allocation Tables, also die sagen, wo jetzt welche Blöcke zu welcher Datei gehören, am Anfang des Datalsystems. Wenn es nur dieses eine Datalsystem auf der Platte gibt, also im äußeren Bereich, weil eigentlich die Platten immer von außen nach innen beschrieben werden. Wenn ich jetzt im äußeren Bereich eben eine Beschädigung habe, die, sag ich mal, ein Kopfbreit ist, dann kann ich eigentlich zu 90 Prozent der Fälle sagen, dass beide Fads weg sind.
Damit jegliche Information darüber, wo überhaupt sich irgendetwas befindet, auch wenn die Daten selber natürlich da noch rumliegen.
Die ist dann einfach davon betroffen. Und wenn wir jetzt Unix-Datalsysteme nehmen, die eine Ordnungsstruktur, sogenannte Cylinder oder Block-Groups haben, da wird einfach die Platte oder jetzt der Platz für dieses Dateisystem so in Häppchen eingeteilt und jedes dieser Häppchen hat im Prinzip seine eigene Einnot-Table, seine eigene Bitmap für die Block-Belegung und ist für sich abgeschlossen praktisch eine eigene Einheit. Das heißt also, wenn ich diese Einheit herausreiße aus dem Dateisystem, ergibt die eben in aller Regel für sich genommen Sinn und braucht eben den Rest nicht. Das heißt, es gibt da eben verschiedene Strategien, Dateisysteme aufzusetzen oder auch zu konstruieren. Und da ist eben ein FAT-Dateisystem sehr empfindlich. Oder beispielsweise bei den Dateisystemen, die diese Tabellen haben, diese Master File Table oder Index Files, die sind natürlich besonders empfindlich dafür, dass wenn eben in diesen Master File Tabels oder Index Files eine Lücke ist, dann ist eben für die Dateien, die in dieser Lücke ihre Meta-Information hatten, ist die Meta-Information halt weg.
Vielleicht können wir ja mal, also um sich das so ein bisschen plastisch vorzustellen, weil wir haben ja auch ein paar Exkrumente gestern auch mal gemacht, um mal ein bisschen in das Thema einzusteigen. Vielleicht können wir mal so am Beispiel dieser typischen Unix File System, die sind ja nun extrem verbreitet, also insbesondere natürlich in der Open Source Welt. Oh Gott, jetzt werde ich hier angerufen. Das kann ich eigentlich nur ablehnen. Vielleicht können wir ja mal so ein bisschen klarmachen, wie so eine Fallsystemstruktur eigentlich tatsächlich aussieht. Also du hast ja schon gesagt, von Anfang an wird erstmal die Festplatte in verschiedene Gruppen aufgeteilt. Warum wird das gemacht?
Na, ich weiß nicht, was du mit Gruppen meinst.
Diese Cylinder-Groups.
Ach so, alles klar. Ja gut, die Festplatte wird ja zunächst mal in Partitionen oder Slices aufgeteilt und in diesen Partitionen oder Slices da spielt sich dann ein Dateisystem ab im Regelfall. Und dieses Dateisystem eben im Falle der UFS-artigen Dateisysteme, also die meisten Unix-Dateisysteme gehen auf das UFS zurück. Da wird eben erstmal der gesamte oder alle Speicherblöcke werden eben erstmal in so, ich sag mal, in gleichgroße Häppchen zerteilt, eben in einige, gerne mal einige hundert gleichgroße Häppchen, die man dann eben Cylinder oder Block Groups nennt und die eben ihre eigene Verwaltungsstruktur jeweils integriert haben. Das heißt also, dass es jetzt nicht irgendwo am Anfang konzentriert oder irgendwo in der Mitte oder am Ende konzentriert, sondern dass eben dadurch die Meta-Information auch gleichmäßig über die Platte verteilt ist. Dass also ein lokaler Schaden nicht dazu führt, dass alles weg ist.
Und diese Meta-Information startet jetzt im Falle von UFS mit dem Superblock?
Richtig. Ja, gut, der Superblock, den haben eigentlich alle Dateisysteme. Weil der Superblock, gut, der heißt jetzt beispielsweise beim NTFS, heißt der anders. Da heißt der NTFS Boot-Rekord, aber ist letztlich auch ein Superblock. Denn das ist eigentlich, enthält der eben die Information über die Geometrie des Dateisystems. Das heißt also, jedes Dateisystem hat so ein paar Geometrie- Informationen, wie beispielsweise die im Unix-Bereich, nennt man es, die Blockgröße. Das heißt also, wie viele physikalische Plattenblocks passen in einen logischen Block. Bei NTFS oder FAD, da hat eben dieselbe Information einen anderen Namen. Da heißt es eben Cluster. Da ist also eine Gruppierung oder da wird eben der gesamte Bereich in Cluster eingeteilt, die eben typischerweise ein Vielfaches der physikalischen Blockgröße dieser Platte sind, um eben einfach die, sag ich jetzt mal, ja, also man macht das eben, um die Pointer auf diese Blöcke verkürzen zu können oder das man eben...
Also im Prinzip, das ist sehr wichtige Informationen, ohne die man eigentlich mit dem Fallsystem so nichts anfangen kann. Sprich, wenn so ein Superblock, oder wie auch jetzt mal heißen mag, bei dem jeweiligen Fallsystem, wenn diese Hauptinformation nicht auffindbar ist oder zerstört ist, dann ist schon mal schlimm.
Ja, dann ist es eigentlich für den normalen Betriebssystem-Treiber vorbei. Der kann dann auf dieses Dateisystem nicht mehr zugreifen, weil er eben diese Geometrie-Informationen nicht mehr hat. Also nicht mehr weiß, wo er seine Mittelinformationen suchen gehen soll. Und wenn er das nicht weiß, dann gibt er im Allgemeinen auf.
Und was kann man da jetzt in der Analyse machen, wenn man jetzt diese Daten dann wieder retten will? Angenommen, der Superblock ist jetzt beschädigt.
Na ja, man kann sie sozusagen aus dem Kaffeesatz lesen. Das heißt also, man versucht Hinweise darauf zu finden, wie diese Geometriedaten wohl ausgesehen haben. Und das kann man eben beispielsweise tun, indem man sich spezialisierte Programme schreibt, also Scanner schreibt, die je nach bestimmten Dateisysteminformationen fahnden. Und versucht die dann eben in diesen Geometrie-Zusammenhang zu stellen, um dann den Superblock wieder nachzubauen. So mal vorsichtig formuliert. Das sind natürlich auch eine Menge Techniken, die da eine Rolle spielen, aber dass man sich das mal vorstellen kann, wie man es eigentlich macht. Man guckt sich das einfach an und sagt, guck mal, das hier sieht aus wie ein Zylinder-Group-Header und der ist komischerweise immer im Abstand von, was weiß ich, 65.536 Blöcken. Oh, das ist ja merkwürdig.
Und dann kann man sich vor allem auch, also sieht so aus, also haben die so einen speziellen Magic-Value noch irgendwie?
Ja, in manchen Dateisystemen haben sie den, in anderen wiederum haben sie den nicht. Das heißt, also dann muss der Scanner eben in der Lage sein, eine Plausibilitätskontrolle der vorgefundenen Werte zu machen, um damit eben festzustellen, ah, das wird wahrscheinlich diese oder jene Dateisystemstruktur sein.
Okay, das heißt jetzt, sagen wir mal, der Superblock war im Eimer, aber wir haben jetzt einen anderen Superblock gefunden, der enthält dann so die meisten Infos. Aktualisiert wird ja, glaube ich, immer nur einer.
Ja, bei den Unix-Dateisystemen wird im Regelfall immer nur der erste Superblock aktualisiert oder eben immer nur einer, wobei eben sicher die Geometrie des Dateisystems über die gesamte Betriebszeit des Dateisystems eigentlich nicht ändert. Insofern kann man eben auch einen Backup-Superblock dazu einsetzen, um die Geometrieinformationen daraus zu lesen. Auch wenn beispielsweise jetzt das letzte Mount-Datum nicht korrekt ist oder irgendso was, das spielt ja eigentlich keine Rolle, um an die Daten heranzukommen. Da ist eigentlich nur die Geometrie von Bedeutung.
So, jetzt, wo wir die Geometrie haben, dann letztlich will man ja an die Dateien ran. Die Dateien sind natürlich auf irgendwelchen Blöcken gespeichert, aber interessant ist natürlich, jetzt die Struktur zu finden, die sagt, welche dieser Blöcke zu welcher Datei gehören, und das in welcher Reihenfolge. Das ist dann bei Unix die Inode-Table.
Na, die Inode-Table nicht, sondern die Inode-Table eigentlich ist sozusagen die Liste aller Inodes, die zu einer Cylinder-Group gehören.
Genau, also eine Inode repräsentiert quasi eine Datei.
Ja, oder kann eben auch ein Link repräsentieren, muss also nicht unbedingt physikalisch auf eine Datei zeigen. Es kann auch sein, dass es einfach ein Link ist. Es gibt ja im Unix-Dateisystem die Möglichkeit, dass mehr als ein Inode auf eine Datei zeigen kann. Das wären dann die Hardlinks.
Na gut, es ist mir dann letztlich egal, über welchen der Inods ich die finde. Hauptsache, ich finde die Datei. Die Frage ist, finde ich überhaupt erst mal diesen Inod, weil auch diese Struktur kann ja kaputt sein.
Ja, also wenn eben diese spezielle Inod beschädigt ist, dann werde ich normal über das Dateisystem die Datei nicht mehr finden, oder jetzt das Betriebssystem benutzt die Inods, um die Dateien zu finden. Die sind eben genauso wichtig wie diese MFT-Records bei NTFS beispielsweise. MFT-Record weg heißt, oder auch Inod weg heißt, Metainformation weg. Das heißt, die Datei ist also ohne den Inod so nicht über den normalen Weg wieder zuzugreifen oder wiederherzustellen.
Ich meine, was ist denn so dein Hauptkritikpunkt an den Dateisystemen heutzutage? Und siehst du da eigentlich irgendeine Verbesserung im Hinblick auf, kann auch mal kaputt gehen und man muss dann mal was wiederfinden? Wo könnte denn da eine Weiterentwicklung oder wo müsste da eine Weiterentwicklung ansetzen, um das zu verbessern?
Ich bin mir noch nicht mal darüber im Klaren, ob das überhaupt wünschenswert ist und ob das die Aufgabe eines Dateisystems ist. Also da muss ich wirklich mit den Dateisystem- Entwicklern gehen und sagen, kann das unser Problem sein? Denn man muss ja diese Dateisysteme nach sehr vielen verschiedenen Zielvorgaben optimieren. Die Leute wollen vom Dateisystem in erster Linie mal im Betrieb eine Performance sehen. Die wollen, dass es schnell ist.
Ja gut, aber sowas einfaches wie ein Magic-Value in einem Superblock, um zu sagen, hier, ich bin leicht zu erkennen, das kann ja nicht unbedingt von Nachteil sein und das hat ja für Performance keinerlei Auswirkungen.
Ist richtig. Die Erhöhung der Erkennbarkeit der Dateisystemstrukturen auf dem Datenträger ist auf jeden Fall eine Forderung, die man darstellen könnte. Einige Dateisysteme liefern das eben auch schon. Die haben eigentlich in praktisch in fast jeder Struktur eine Art Magic Number drin, womit das Wiederfinden eben erleichtert wird.
Also von dem modernen Betriebssystem, von dem moderneren Fallsystem.
Ja, ja.
Bei Fett ist das wahrscheinlich nicht so der Fall.
Nein, das ist nicht so der Fall. Aber das ist halt, ja gut, das ist halt historisch gewachsen.
Es gibt ja auch im Dateisystembereich, gibt es ja auch durchaus Bewegung, also abgesehen von dem täglichen religiösen Krieg, was ja nun das Beste sei. Es gibt ja vor allem sehr viele unterschiedliche Ansätze, um auch eine automatische Wiederherstellung da zu gewinnen. Also angefangen hat man überhaupt erst mal sicherzustellen, dass die Schreibzugriffe so halbwegs automar sind. Also da gibt es ja irgendwie Soft-Updates. Bei FreeBSD fallen wir da zuerst ein und natürlich dann die Journaling-Funktionalitäten, die, glaube ich, in Reiser FS und in HFS Plus zu finden sind.
Journaling gibt es ja inzwischen auch für X2. Das ist ja im Grunde genommen X3.
Genau, das habe ich noch vergessen.
X2 plus Journaling.
Richtig. Kannst du das mal beschreiben, wie die vorgehen?
Ja, das ist halt eine Transaktionsliste, die zu einer Konsistenz der Metadaten zu jedem Zeitpunkt sicherstellen soll. So dass man beispielsweise, wenn man einfach irgendwo einen Stecker rausgezogen hat, sich den Dateisystem-Check spart. Das hat aber auch nichts mit den Daten selbst zu tun, sondern es hat einzig und allein mit den Metadaten zu tun. Das Dateisystem ist in sich konsistent. Es kann aber trotzdem noch sein, dass in der Datei, die jetzt für dich wichtig ist, weil es Unsinn drinsteht. Das hat damit eben nichts zu tun. Dieses Thema ist wirklich sehr komplex, weil es eben auch mit Caching zu tun hat. Das heißt also, moderne Festplatten haben ja auch Write-Caches, das heißt, die nehmen den Schreibbefehl im Gegen und sagen, jawohl, Schreibbefehl fertig ausgeführt, aber in Wirklichkeit befinden sich die Daten noch in deren Ram. Wenn man dann den Stecker rauszieht, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr gering, dass die noch ihren Weg auf den magnetischen Datenträger finden. Man kann eben für eine Konsistenz der Metadaten sorgen. Das heißt also, dass ein Datalsystem zu keinem Zeitpunkt eigentlich in einem unklaren Zustand ist. Der kann aber eben immer noch sinnlos sein.
Mit anderen Worten, alles gar nicht so einfach in der Datalsystemwelt. Es gibt ja auch neue Entwicklungen. Was mir vor kurzem über den Weg gelaufen ist, meine Aufmerksamkeit an sich gezogen hat, ist das neue ZFS-Fallsystem von Sun, was bei Open Solaris dabei ist, wo sie noch irgendwie am entwickeln sind, aber was zumindest schon mal läuft. Da haben sie ja schon ein paar nette Sachen eingebaut, also unter anderem, und ich glaube, da sind sie auch die ersten, haben sie eine Prüfsumme für jeden Block auf der Festplatte mit drauf. Ich dürfte einen doch freuen, oder?
Na ja, das ist im Prinzip beispielsweise für Daten und der Datensretterungsgesichtspunkten eigentlich vollkommen uninteressant, weil die Festplatten-Elektronik ohnehin für sich schon von jedem Block eine Prüfsumme macht. Warum soll ich die in Software nochmal machen? Diese Prüfsumme sagt ja auch nichts darüber aus, was in diesem Block gespeichert ist.
Also auf jeder Festplatte ist generell jeder Block durch Prüfsumme gesichert?
Ja, also sage ich jetzt mal durch einen Mechanismus. Bei allen modernen Festplatten ist eben ein Error-Correction-Code-Mechanismus drin. Das heißt also selbst wenn dort ein paar Bits umgefallen sind von einem Block, dann kann eben die Platten-Elektronik das immer noch mathematisch korrigieren. Das heißt also es kommen immer noch die richtigen Daten hinten raus, obwohl tatsächlich Bits umgefallen sind. Das sind halt die verschiedenen ECC, Error-Correction Codes.
Es gibt ja auch diese Technologien, wie heißt das noch gleich, diese Smart, ist das richtig, Smart, wo die Festplatten selber über ihren Zustand Auskunft geben?
Ja, allerdings würde ich davon jetzt nicht zu viel erwarten, denn eigentlich soll das ja im Prinzip, ich glaube, IBM hat das Ganze angefangen, da hieß es Predict the Failure Analysis. Das bedeutet also, dass die Platte irgendwie selber merken soll, dass sie stirbt.
I'm dying, I'm dying. My mind is going.
In manchen Fällen mag das wohl auch funktionieren, nur ist es also, die Praxis ist einfach die, dass in den seltensten Fällen oder in wenigen Fällen die Leute tatsächlich davor gewarnt werden, dass etwas passiert. Und es kann ja eben auch ein äußerer Einfluss sein, woher soll das Maat wissen, dass du deinen Laptop runtergeschmissen hast, nicht? Das sind halt, wenn sich so bestimmte Dinge tun, also beispielsweise wenn bestimmte Fehlerraten steigen und so etwas, dann wird das alles registriert in der Plattenelektronik. Ob sie dann Ton gibt, das hängt noch von vielen Faktoren ab, denn natürlich möchte auch der Plattenhersteller seine RMA-Quote möglichst gering halten. Das heißt, das ist immer so eine Art Abwägung zwischen den Interessen. Ja, also sozusagen die Rücksende-Quote für defekte Platten. Innerhalb der Garantiezeit möchte er natürlich möglichst gering halten. Wenn er nun da, sag ich jetzt mal, mit dieser vorausschauenden Fehleranalyse da eben zu empfindlich ist, dann kriegt er halt einfach mal die Hälfte seiner Produktion zurückgeschickt. Wenn er damit zu unempfindlich ist, dann taugt sie halt für den Benutzer nichts mehr. Das heißt also, dass die Platte sagt, ich hab hier ein Problem, leider kann ich deine Daten nicht mehr lesen.
Jetzt hast du ja gesagt, wenn der Laptop runterfällt, dann hilft mir das nicht. Moderne Laptops haben jetzt schon diese Schock-Sensoren drin oder die Bewegungs-Sensoren, die quasi merken, wenn sie vom Tisch fallen und dann auch versuchen, da Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, indem sie Daten sichern, weiß nicht, Buffer-Flaschen, was die im Einzelnen machen, aber teilweise gibt es auch Festplatten, die das eingebaut haben.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also Buffer-Flaschen wäre nun das, was ich gerade nicht tun würde, wenn der Laptop runterfällt. Sondern ich würde einfach mal sagen, wenn eben vorherzusehen ist, dass eine hohe Beschleunigung auf die Festplatte wirkt, dann würde ich mal bei Laptop-Festplatten die Köpfe auf die Slider fahren, damit die sozusagen die Gefahr reduziert wird, dass sie auf den Oberflächen einschlagen.
Das heißt, der Kopf wird ganz rausgefahren?
Ganz raus, ganz raus aus den Oberflächen und eben auf so ein kleines Plastikklötzchen da, wo so Rampen drauf sind, die nennen, also naja, halt, wir nennen sie halt Slider und da sind dann eben, an der Stelle sind die Köpfe dann eben weniger empfindlich, als wenn sie auf ein rotierendes Medium einschlagen. Und dann würde ich sie eben, also würde ich sie eben da auch mal ein paar Sekunden lassen.
Bevor man wieder anfängt zu zocken.
Genau. Das heißt also, das ist eigentlich, würde ich mal sagen, die Strategie der Wahl, wenn die Platte merkt, ich falle.
Das heißt, auf so ein Laptop muss man demnächst mal so ein Sticker drauf machen, bitte nicht schütteln, damit sich überhaupt noch was tut.
Na ja, gut, es passiert ja eigentlich nichts weiter, denn jetzt der Laptop, jetzt der Computer wird ja so lange warten, bis er seine Anfrage von der Platte beantwortet bekommt. Das heißt also, wenn die Platte jetzt einfach mal zwei Sekunden auf dem Slider geparkt hat, passiert ja gar nichts, außer dass deine Anwendung vielleicht ein bisschen hakt und dann geht's weiter. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass die Platte dann sozusagen sagt, ich spreche nicht mehr mit dir, sondern sie verhält sich durchaus noch definiert an der Schnittstelle, nur dass sie halt mechanisch mal versucht, eben ihre Köpfe in Sicherheit zu bringen.
Und keine Daten liefert.
Genau.
Das ist ja auch wünschenswert an der Stelle. Ja, ich will kein Produkt-Bashing betreiben, aber gibt's so irgendwie in der langen Zeit, gab's irgendwie ein spezielles Modell der Vergangenheit, was besonders viel Ärger gemacht hat?
Na, die gab es immer wieder. Und die Fehler waren eben auch bei den verschiedenen Serien, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, recht unterschiedlich. Also es gab halt mal... Also ich möchte auch kein Produkt-Bashing betreiben, weil eigentlich jeder Hersteller hat schon ein Problem gehabt. Der eine hatte ein mechanisches Problem, dass irgendwie ihm die Scheiben regelmäßig abgehobelt hat. Der andere hatte halt ein Firmware-Problem, dass die Platte halt eben Teile ihrer plappenseitigen Firmware unter bestimmten Umständen vergessen hat und dann einfach nicht mehr gebootet hat. Also es gibt da noch... da hat sich... Also wie soll ich sagen? Also da kann man wirklich nicht mit dem Finger auf irgendeinen zeigen.
Das haben sie alle gehabt. Ich wollte jetzt auch keinen speziellen nennen, weil es ist klar, dass man da irgendwie sowieso immer die falschen trifft. Aber es gibt natürlich auch so bestimmte dumme Fehler, die in Software immer gemacht werden. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Hard-Disc-Entwickler da groß vor gefeilt sind, solche Fehler zu machen.
Die sind davor auch nicht sicher, das ist klar. Es gibt natürlich auch einen großen Strauß von Software-Fehlern innerhalb dieser Controller-Boards, die dann eben auch Zustände hervorrufen können, die eine Datenrettung unter Umständen erforderlich machen.
Gut, ich denke, das war jetzt mal ein super Roundup. Einmal quer durch die Festplatte und zurück. Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen. Und wenn ihr Anmerkungen habt, wie gehabt, wir sind offen für Feedback unter chaosradio.ccc.de oder ihr ruft unsere tolle Telefonnummer an, die ich jetzt gerade mal nicht notiert habe und jetzt auch keine Lust habe, aufzusagen. Ihr findet das alles unter chaosradio.ccc.de genauso wie unsere anderen Kanäle ChaosTV und natürlich auch Chaos Radio, die regelmäßige Sendung immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat auf Fritz und danach eben auch im Podcast im Internet. Ende dieses Monats ist es also wieder soweit. Das Thema werden wir demnächst bekannt geben. Und bis dahin hoffe ich, dass ihr uns als Zuhörer gewogen bleibt. Und wir sagen jetzt hier mal Tschüss. Und bis bald auf diesem Kanal.